[Music]
we are gearing up for crimes of
Grindelwald and we know you obsessed
Harry Potter fans are too we dug deep
into the Harry Potter universe to find
those rare and not so rare moments that
meet up in fantastic beasts watch to the
end to find out a huge spoiler you may
have missed in the final trailer wizard
don't forget to hit that notification
bell to never miss another video and be
sure to check out our community section
for even more fun now let's unpack 10
moments when fantastic beasts meets
Harry Potter world in new movies
Gellert Grindelwald we'll start off with
the movie's namesake it only makes sense
to lead with our lead who appeared in
both the Harry Potter series and
fantastic beasts Gellert Grindelwald
first appeared briefly in The Sorcerer's
Stone when Harry Potter purchases some
Wizarding sweets on the Hogwarts Express
including some chocolate frogs we see
Grindelwald on the back of Albus
Dumbledore's chocolate frog card as the
dark wizard that Dumbledore defeated in
1945 however we later learn in the
Deathly Hallows that Grindelwald was
more than just the Dark Wizard -
Dumbledore
they were like total frenemies again
Grindelwald and Dumbledore had made
plans to lead a Wizarding revolution
however after altercation between
himself his brother and Grindelwald
Dumbledore parted ways
while Gilbert went on to build his army
he was eventually defeated by Dumbledore
and locked up in the very prison he
built to hold those who opposed him
Nermin guard it was there many years
later where he defiantly lied to
Voldemort's about never having possessed
the Elder Wand a move Dumbledore could
only hope was his attempt to make amends
geez boys can you tone down the drama
Albus Dumbledore an even more obvious
character appearing in both franchises
is a certain headmaster of Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry in the
second fantastic beasts movie we will
see Albus Dumbledore who has not yet
taken the position of headmaster after
his falling out with Grindelwald he
summons Newt Scamander for help he felt
as though he himself would not be able
to take on his former friend new
had been a student of Dumbledore's at
Hogwarts when threatened with expulsion
Dumbledore had his back
whether newts expulsion was enforced or
not is unknown but Dumbledore succeeded
in at least allowing Newt to keep his
wand so we know Dumbledore had a soft
spot for Newt and could rely on him to
help takedown Grindelwald it was rumored
that Newt travelled to Paris on
Dumbledore's orders which reached the
British Ministry of Magic a delegation
was sent to Hogwarts castle to question
Dumbledore so it seems the student with
all the pets ended up the teachers feds
clever ah we thought so
Nagini we see Nagini many times
throughout the Harry Potter series as
what is first assumed to be simply Valda
morts cut snake he used her to do his
bidding attacking those who opposed him
or got in his way she had other purposes
as well one being her venom used as part
of a potion in order to regain the vmon
strength however we later find out in
the half-blood Prince that she is also a
Horcrux which explains the strong bond
between herself and her owner during the
second Wizarding war Nagini had to be
destroyed in order for Baldy to finally
be defeated and we all remember who
sliced her in half right we may not have
expected it but Neville Longbottom came
through for Harry Potter in the end now
if you're avoiding spoilers you may want
to turn down your volume for this next
part when we meet Nagini in the Harry
Potter series
she is seemingly trapped in snake form
but as we will learn in fantastic beasts
the crimes of Grindelwald
she once had the ability to transform
from human to snake at will we could go
on about her origin story and which
important character brought her to
Grindelwald but that's enough of a
spoiler for now don't be salty oh yeah
you hardcore Potter fans can turn your
volume back up let's imagine okay we
must admit that these three are just two
guesses but we can't be the only ones
hoping to see at the very least a cameo
in an upcoming fantastic beast movie and
it turns out we aren't cinema blend calm
dropped these brilliant characters into
our minds with their guesses on who
could appear in future fantastic beasts
movies first up Tom Riddle sure he
wasn't even a twinkle in his unloving
father's eye during the time for
classic beasts and where to find them
would have occurred but as cinema Blin
mentions what if the storyline were to
jump ahead a few years into the future
and place Newt Scamander in the path of
a very young Tom also would it make
Simms for a perform well door to make an
appearance it would certainly be an
opportunity for us to get to know the
Headmaster's brother a bit better Newt
could encounter Aberforth at the
hogshead while visiting Hogwarts and
thirdly Bathilda Bagshot she may seem
like a random addition to this list but
she may also be the most appropriate
character included here to grace the
fantastic beasts movies with an
appearance like Newt Scamander she also
contributed to Hogwarts by penning one
of the textbooks the students study
titled a history of magic what do you
think would these characters make sense
in the fantastic beasts world let us
know in the comments defensive defensive
is an enchanted basin that allows its
owner to experience and store memories
before they are forgotten we are first
introduced to this in the Goblet of Fire
when Harry accidentally looked inside
and found himself watching a series of
trials and Sinton scenes the pensive
continues to appear throughout the
Potter series as a flashback narrative
device the pensive doesn't exactly
appear in the fantastic beasts and where
to find them but the ideas utilized in
the death Sal scene where Newt and Tina
have been sentenced to death by the
magical Congress of the United States of
America
executioner's would use a memory
extraction spell to draw out fond
memories from the condemned and cast
them into a pool filled with death
potion the pool would replay these
memories just like a pensive while the
condemned were slowly lowered into the
potion while hovering in a chair the
potion was highly corrosive and would
burn the chair and whoever sat in it a
bit of an overkill don't you think Newt
Scamander and Tina Goldstein were led
here by the executioner's in order to
carry out the sentence imposed by
Percival graves who was really
Grindelwald disguised as graves they
were saved at the very last second by
queenie goldstein and dick of Kowalski
with one of newts amazing beasts a
swooping evil coup
Merlin's beard okay after the heavy
deaths L talk we need to lighten things
up with a fun one as dark as fantastic
beasts and harrypotter can get we still
enjoy the whimsy and fun our favorite
author and screenwriter
JK Rowling gives us the Wizard of
etherion legend was one of the most
celebrated of all time The Wizarding
World even has the order of Merlin to
honor Wizarding kind the expression
Merlin's beard can be heard in both
Harry Potter and fantastic beast movies
it is the same as saying OMG in muggle
language you can hear different
variations of the term in the Harry
Potter series depending on who is saying
it at one point Merlin's pants is
uttered as well as Merlin's most baggy
y-fronts
said by Ron Weasley we aren't sure what
that one means but we're not going to
try to find out and almost everyone from
the Ministry of Magic blurted out Merlin
isms regularly knew tis hard using the
phrase in fantastic beasts as well as
Horace Slughorn and Cedric Diggory so we
can assume innocent version is more
commonly used by the older generation
we've been having fun coming up with new
ways of saying Merlin's beard over here
at the things how would you say it show
us in the comments and keep watching to
find out what crazy spoiler fantastic
beasts revealed in its final trailer
Hogwarts we've already mentioned you'll
be seeing a younger and very handsome we
must add Albus Dumbledore in the
upcoming fantastic beasts movie what we
have yet to mention is that the story
will be travelling across the pond to
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry it should go without saying
that the hogwarts does appear in every
harry potter movie but if you didn't
know that what are you doing watching
this video go watch the movies back at
hogwarts we get to see a young
Dumbledore teach a young newt to face
his de mentor which is a desk in the
second trailer for fantastic beasts the
crimes of Grindelwald news reveals his
biggest fear is having to work in an
office
maybe muggles and wizards aren't so
different after all think about it if us
muggles get tired and grumpy from
sitting behind a boring desk in a boring
office at a boring job every boring day
wouldn't you think that Wizards would
find it drab and undesirable as well or
imagine the complete opposite of boring
like when Harry Ron and Hermione snuck
into the ministry
magic to steal one of Baltimore
Horcruxes they took Polyjuice potion to
take the form of three unsuspecting
employees it was so intense we couldn't
imagine ourselves taking that sort of
risk no way give us a job flipping
burgers any day
Clemont Potter fantastic beast is the
type of film that has so much going on
it is way too easy to miss the little
things unless you are a professional
Potter fan you may have missed this fun
Easter egg did you know Harry Potter's
grandfather actually makes an appearance
in fantastic beasts and where to find
them
it's true though if you blinked you for
sure missed it during the opening
sequence of the first fantastic beasts
movie we see a fast moving montage of
newspapers and formulas of Grindelwald
rise we see the New York Ghost with
their headline Grindelwald attacks
intensify risking war with no maj and
the Daily Prophet with Hogwarts School
increases security if you paused just at
the right moment you can find fun little
articles and advertisements on the front
pages for instance in the u.s. newspaper
we read that wand permits renewal is
mandatory for all American Wizards the
daily profit includes an article about
flea montz potion wooing American
Wizards Clemens Potter came from an
already wealthy family who after
graduating as a Gryffindor from Hogwarts
became a potion heir and created sleek
Easy's hair potion
the slogan was to drop stain even the
most bothersome Barnett's it was a good
potion too it was noted on the label as
being suitable for all hair types and it
was particularly effective at taming
bushy unruly hair however the label did
caution against use of the products by
redheads warning it would have unique
results for them Hermione Granger
apparently used this potion and a lot of
it for the Yule Ball and the Goblet of
Fire
it is said that flea menthe Potter's
hair potion was so successful this was
how Harry Potter inherited all his gold
didn't think your mum and dad would
leave you with nothing though did you
Nicholas Flamel Nicholas Flamel is one
of the most influential characters in
the first Harry Potter story yet never
actually made an appearance in the movie
except for a brief mention of his name
JK Rowling describes him as a historical
character who lived in France in the
14th century and is supposed to have
discovered how to make a philosopher's
stone this makes him capable of
producing the elixir of life granting
him mortality the danger of the stones
existence was brought to light when
Voldemort was nearly successful in
stealing it in order to restore himself
to physical form we all know what
happened next Harry Ron and Hermione
kicked some major Vee Duty booty Flamel
and Dumbledore both agreed the stone
should be destroyed
although Flamel and his wife's lives
would not last much longer once the
stone was destroyed we are happy to go
back in time to fantastic beasts we see
him in the trailer for the upcoming
fantastic beasts in a fun scene with
Newt Scamander and our comical muggle
Jacob Kowalski who mistook him for a
ghost lettle is strange okay here it is
people if you haven't already done your
research prepare to have your mind blown
first let's get to know little estrange
just a little bit more she is the woman
in the picture that Newt Scamander
carries around and who Queenie asks
about from the scene we learned they
were friends in school we don't know how
their friendship ended just that Newt
was deeply hurt by it if you find the
nameless strange familiar you should
Bellatrix black married into the
Lestrange family her husband Rudolph is
Lestrange is thought by some to be
either a direct descendant or indirect
descendent of led of a strange and
that's not all the final trailer for the
upcoming fantastic beasts movie drops a
huge clue alright for those who want to
avoid spoilers here is your warning in
the trailer there is a split second
glance at a distant chart it's only
pictured for a moment while an unknown
character standing in a dimly lit room
inspects a wall filled with what looks
like graffiti but if you zoom in on the
scene you'll find that it's a family
tree of sorts
and wait for us it connects the tortured
obscuri ol credence barebone to none
other than lettle estranged boot you
never met the monster you couldn't love
according to the chart both credence and
Letta are the children of Corvus
Lestrange but by different mothers
making them half siblings so you tell us
were you surprised by any of these or
are you one of the top elite pro potters
who knows it all do you have any guesses
as to who else may be visiting fantastic
beasts from the Harry Potter world let
us know in the comments and that's it
for 10 moments when fantastic beasts
meets Harry Potter world in the new
movies thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]